alona la grande nouvelle je me marie 18
quines commet une erreur monumentale
la venue à las vegas je veux que vous y
alliez tout ce dont vous avez de la
drogue des bêtabloquants ça vous dit on
va s'éclater comme ans 59 ça va être un
week-end de folie
[Applaudissements]
vodka red bull je souhaite retrouver sa
malice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est curieux ce mélange vodka red bull
j'ai l'impression d'être en train de
prendre une cuite homme électrocuté
groupe totalise sur la piste de danse
mais comme d'habitude j'habite une
partenaire il y en a ne semble pas
déranger pas peut-être que je vais quand
même essayer
et puis non